[Musique]
et
bienvenue sur le plateau d'un tas dix
dates à venir la loi sur le séparatisme
rebaptisée loi portant les principes
républicains est censée lutter contre
l'islamisme radical
en modifiant la loi sur les cultes et en
luttant contre le repli communautaire
marlène schiappa également annoncé la
prochaine dissolution de l'observatoire
de la laïcité qui devrait être remplacée
par une structure qui porterait la
parole de l'état c'est ce qu'elle a dit
alors qu'est-ce que c'en est fini de la
laïcité telle que nous la connaissions
et par quoi va-t-on l'a remplacé et
quels sont ces valeurs républicaines que
l'on arrête pas d'invoquer ses principes
républicains que l'on veut conforter
pour un débattre nous avons invité deux
hommes jean baubérot et marcel gaucher
jean baubérot bonsoir vous êtes
historien sociologue vous avez été
titulaire de la chaire histoire et
sociologie de la laïcité
de 1991 à 2007 à l'école pratique des
hautes études dont vous êtes aujourd'hui
le président d'honneur cette hauteur de
plus de 30 livres dont la plupart
concernent la laïcité y compris votre
unique roman improbables amours qui
vient de reparaître en version intégrale
aux éditions de la libre pensée
enfin vous venait d'adresser une lettre
ouverte à emmanuel macron qui s'est
souvent référés avoué qui jusqu'à
présent
défendez la même conception peut que
vous de la laïcité lettre ouverte dans
laquelle vous le supplier je me suis dit
de ne pas se laisser influencer par le
sarkozysme sur ce sujet et plus
largement par la droite manuel valls
compris alors petite question le projet
de loi comportant le respect des
principes républicains vous voyez cela
comme une trahison de la laïcité
française
je vois cela surtout comme un texte
contreproductif qui va aggraver ce qui
prétend combattre et qui risque
d'augmenter l'attractivité de
l'extrémisme et après on proposera
encore de nouvelles lois et on est dans
un engrenage qui à mon avis est un peu
fatale marcel gaucher vous êtes
philosophe directeur d'études et mairie
tu à l'école des hautes études en
sciences sociales vous avez été le
rédacteur en chef de la revue le débat
de sa naissance en 1980 jusqu'à son
sabordement il y à un mois ou deux vous
êtes l'auteur du désenchantement du
monde et de la région et la religion
dans la démocratie qui sont parus tous
les deux chez gallimard
dès 2016 vous disiez dans une interview
dans les échos que nous allions devoir
revenir à une laïcité de combat
est ce que c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui pour vous avec cette loi non
cette loi ne correspond pas à une unité
de combat à mon sens d'ailleurs il elle
traite une partie de la question sans
aborder de front le essentiel des
questions qui sont posées au titre de la
laïcité et de la république de questions
connexes mais distinctes et je crois que
nous sommes donc dans the en réalité
dans un statu quo aménagé qui ne
traitera pas le qui fait qu'on aura
probablement là je rejoins jean baubérot
d'autres lois que temple empirait pour
les uns améliorées pour les autres un
dispositif qui reste assez flou dans ses
termes exacts tels que je peux
aujourd'hui apprécier ce que nous savons
de ce texte de loi qui a été publiée que
je n'ai pas étudié en détail je lave ou
tout de suite
alors commençons par les valeurs
républicaines parce que ça fait un
certain temps déjà que les membres du
gouvernement gérald darmanin marlène
schiappa en tête ne cesse d'invoquer les
valeurs républicaines
alors est-ce que depuis quand est ce que
nous sommes sensés tous partager les
mêmes valeurs
on peut être croyant ou athée
monarchistes ou anarchistes on en est
pas moins de bons républicains du moment
qu'on respecte la loi
est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train avec
cette histoire de valeurs républicaines
de trier entre les bons et mauvais
républicain jean baubérot alors on
pourrait dire c'est que la constitution
entrée en bulle
dans ce préambule il ya effectivement un
certain nombre alors moi je préfère
parler de principe plutôt que de valeur
il ya un certain nombre de principes qui
peuvent être par exemple l'enseigné par
l'école sans déroger à la neutralité que
doit avoir l'école par rapport aux
convictions des uns et des autres enfin
donc vous interromps premier en se fiant
baubérot juste on va parler des
principes vous avez raison c'est dans la
pré en bulles de la constitution mais là
je parle des valeurs parce qu'on ne
cesse de nous rabâcher les valeurs
républicaines et ont alors est-ce qu'on
fait semblant de les confondre avec les
principes mais les valeurs ce ne sont
pas les principes et des valeurs
républicaines
à notre connaissance il n'y en a pas et
alors je le comprends pas pourquoi le
ministre elle n'arrête pas de nous en
parler
oui alors c'est évidemment à lui qu'il
faudrait poser la question mais moi je
crois que ce discours sur les valeurs
effectivement c'est un discours clivants
entre des gens qui par essence un petit
peu seraient dans ses valeurs
républicaines les respecterai et puis
d'autres qui avaient à chaque fois
passée une sorte d'examen de passage
pour qu'on soit bien sûr qu' il serait
il respecterait ses les dites valeurs
républicaines
donc c'est un discours à mon avis qui
qui est un discours d'une part flou et
comme dirait l'autre
quand c'est flou jaloux et d'autre part
c'est un discours qui est toujours
donnée quand un certain nombre de gens
notamment les immigrés par exemple ou
des gens de confessions minoritaires
sont en jeu on parle pas de valeurs
républicaines à propos du 16e
arrondissement on parle pas des valeurs
républicaines
à propos de des grands lycées parisiens
où pourtant la république dépense
beaucoup plus d'argent que pour un lycée
de banlieue et que ça tient là donc
c'est vraiment un discours bref je le
qualifierais de structurellement
hypocrite et je ne vois pas justement en
quoi on pouvait imposer des valeurs qui
serait différent d
ainsi peu républicain principe là on
sait de quoi il s'agit il sont dans la
constitution
et on peut s'y référer et il ya en plus
un dispositif juridique qui est lié à
ses principes
voilà même question marcel gauche et les
valeurs républicaines est ce que ça
existe pour vous non je déteste monde à
l'heure qui me paraît égaré les esprits
il est vague et surtout il renvoie à une
quelque chose qui n'est pas en question
dans ce qui nous lie et devrait nous
occuper des valeurs on les évalue elles
sont relatives
donc on peut les on peut mettre le
curseur de ces valeurs on veut
al'inverse les principes sont claires je
vais j'ai de la peine à comprendre
pourquoi ce vocabulaire s'est imposé
d'entrée dans l'espace public alors
qu'il ne sert pas à éclaircir les points
dont nous parlons et les principes
républicains eux
son père même si leur application fait
tout l'objet de notre discussion car je
crois pas qu'il y ait en france
de vraies discussions sur ces principes
oui il ya des manières différentes par
vente de l'élire de d interpréter dont
irène des conséquences pratiques
c'est là qu'est le vrai discussions
d'eau je pense que le calme et le
personnel politique
c'est une erreur en se référant à cette
notion de valeur qu'il ne peut que l'en
bourg b dans des discussions dépourvu de
sens et je suis même pas sûr qu'il
faille y voir
je crains qu'il s'agit simplement de
confusion plus que d'une intention qui
mettrait en avant telle ou telle
catégorie de la population je crois pas
que ce soit l'objet mais pourquoi ne pas
s'en tenir à ce vocabulaire de principe
c'est la petite réforme que je propose
si on peut aussi tenter qu'on puisse
facilement modifier un vocabulaire
politique désormais aussi enracinée
alors balayons les valeurs oublions
l'est attaquons nous aux principes c'est
vrai qu'ils sont claires les principes
républicains mais seulement s'ils sont
si claires que ça dans la mesure où est
ce qu'on les applique réellement par
exemple respect de la liberté
d'expression c'est vraiment un principe
républicain sauf qu'en france tout le
monde sait qu'elle est tout à fait
limité cette liberté d'expression alors
à pays qui ne respecte pas lui même et
une veille un principe républicain qu'il
est censé respecter et voire même
conforté est ce que ça ne pose pas de
problème marcel gaucher nous arrivons là
dans le coeur de la question les
principes républicains à la base ils ont
une source connue de tous qui est la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen à partir de ces droits de
l'homme il s'agit de définir un cadre
politique et ce cadre politique et qui
va supposer des aménagements ses droits
fondamentaux que le régime est supposé
non seulement reconnaître comme base
mais mettre en oeuvre pratique la
question de la liberté d'expression que
vous soulevez qui est l'un des points
sensibles est à cet égard typique
évidemment que la liberté d'expression
n'est pas un droit absolu qui ne
supposerait aucune limitation
nous entrons là dans le dur du sujet
politique c'est à dire ou place-t-on ses
limites ou place-t-on l'inconditionnel
des droits qu'il s'agit d'exercer en
l'occurrence le droit à la libre
expression de ses opinions et de ses
convictions
c'est ça le sujet véritable c'est là des
conditions d'application de droit sur
lesquels nous pouvons être très
largement d'accord très majoritairement
d'accord mais notre nos désaccords forte
sur la façon d'en tirer des conséquences
pratiques
jean baubérot cette liberté d'expression
qu'on a vu qu'on a entendu emmanuel
macron dire
en france on limitera jamais la liberté
d'expression
limite tous les jours oui alors avant je
voulais parler un petit peu des
principes parce que bon effectivement il
ya eu la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen de 1789
mais dès ce moment là il ya eu au club
de goult qui a fait la déclaration des
droits de la femme et de la citoyenne en
dix ans une femme a le droit d'aller sur
l'échafaud une femme doit pouvoir avoir
des d'autres droits égaux à ceux des
hommes et notamment le droit de
s'exprimer le droit de devaux tech
cetera et cetera et elle a été sur
l'échafaud mais elle n'avait pas le
droit effectivement de parler et
s'exprimer publiquement au même titre
que les autres donc dès le départ il ya
une ambiguïté dans la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen dans la
mesure où elle a un univers ce elle se
veut universel mais son universalisme a
été contesté par des gens qui à raison
maintenant pense-t-on s'exprimer
s'estimer pas inclus dans cet
universalisme
surtout qu'après la france a été le pays
démocratique où le différentiel entre le
droit de vote des hommes et le droit de
vote
réellement universel a été le plus bas
alors à cela la déclaration de le
préambule de la constitution de 1946 qui
nous régit toujours ajouter d'autres
droits
donc c'est pas seulement la déclaration
des droits de l'homme c'est aussi les
droits qui sont dans le bloc de
constitutionnalité actuelle et notamment
au niveau de droits sociaux et que sa
terreur etc et la liberté d'expression
c'est pas stricto sensu dans la
déclaration des droits de l'homme c'est
plutôt implicite bon et c'est arrivé de
manière explicite par la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme en 48
et par la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme en 1950 preuve que
la france n'est pas universelle à elle
toute seule et qu'elle peut recevoir
aussi des principes importants de
l'extérieur bon alors là
à partir de là oui il ya un problème
mais à mon avis il ya deux problèmes il
ya le problème effectivement des limites
de la liberté d'expression et et en
france les limites sont quand même assez
forte ces dernières décennies de
diverses lois notamment les lois qu'on a
appelé les lois mémorielles ont
restreint disons la liberté d'expression
alors à tort ou à raison sans peut en
discuter mais à mon avis il ya aussi la
devise républicaine liberté égalité
fraternité
donc il ya aussi le problème de
l'égalité dans l'express l'accès à
l'expression publique et là il ya
vraiment une très très forte inégalité
dans l'accès à l'expression publique n'y
a pas que des inégalités sociales au
sens classique du terme
il ya vraiment aussi une inégalité et
des rapports de force dans l'axé à
l'époque expression publique donc si
vous voulez le débat n'est pas seulement
sur les limites légitime à apporter à la
liberté d'expression
le débat est aussi sur comment faire
pour réduire l'inégalité dans l'accès à
l'expression publique parce que c'est
vraiment un des problèmes majeurs
aujourd'hui qui fait que beaucoup de
gens se sentent atteints dans leur
dignité parce que ils n'ont pas cet
accès à l'expression publique
vous êtes d'accord mars à gauche et oui
on chez typiquement ya le la discussion
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure sur le
passage des principes à leur application
pratique est en effet la liberté
d'expression pour un problème tout à
fait spécifique qui est d'ailleurs une
une question insoluble d'une certaine
manière ce que résume l'expression
populaire quand tout le monde parle
personne n'écoute
donc il ya en effet dans l'idée même
d'une expression partage et une
difficultés considérables à la mettre en
oeuvre
je crois que aucune société ne
parviendra jamais à une parfaite égalité
dans l'expression l'expression est
extraordinairement inégal à tous les
niveaux donc toutes les sociétés et on
peut donc je crois que la question est
résolue en partie dans nos sociétés par
le principe de représentation à dire des
gens qui en effet ne s'exprime pas dans
l'espace public devrait au moins pouvoir
disposer de la possibilité de faire
entendre leur point de vue par des
représentants et l'entier on sait bien
que cette difficulté est très loin
d'être résolue nous sommes dans des
régimes fondamentalement un parfait et
des régimes dont la vie politique tourne
autour de l'idée des progrès qu'ils
peuvent faire oui mais leur matière de
l'application de ces principes
mais alors si on s'intéresse maintenant
à au droit à la caricature au droit au
blasphème qui sont sans cesse revendiqué
en ce moment par par nos politiques
eux aussi sont rudement limité c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire
on n'a pas le droit de caricaturer les
femmes dans des dans des campagnes
publicitaires on le voit en ce moment
avec la campagne saint laurent on
reproche à cette campagne de caricaturer
les femmes on ne peut pas caricaturer
les homosexuels on ne peut pas 40
capturer les gens en fonction de leur
race
quand on dit qu'on a le droit au
blasphème ça n'est pas vrai des enfants
de 10 ans ont été mis en garde à vue
justement parce qu'ils avaient
blasphémer d'aspe mais parce qu'il
n'avait pas respecté la minute de
silence ou parce qu'ils avaient tenu des
propos
qu'on a qualifié d' insupportable sur
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit qu'est ce
que c'est d'autre que du blasphème
on peut blasphémer sans arrêt sur les
femmes sur les homosexuels à propos du
terrorisme est-ce que quand on dit qu'on
n'a pas le droit qu'on a le droit de
blasphémer en france est-ce qu'on se
fout pas de nous jean baubérot alors oui
bon moi d'abord j'ai un problème avec ce
mode glace faible parce que ce mot
transcendant un univers religieux donc
là le par les laïcs je dirais vous par
les républicains ne devrait pas
s'attaquer aux fins s'intéressait aux
terres de blasphème
ils devraient plutôt justement parler de
la liberté d'expression en général et
des raisons légitimes qu'on pourrait
avoir de limiter cette liberté
d'expression alors ce qui est tout à
fait juste dans ce que vous dites c'est
qu'effectivement il n'y a pas de non
seulement il n'y a pas un égal accès à
la liberté d'expression et le fait que
jamais il y aura un égal accès n'empêche
pas de lutter contre la très grande
inégalité dans la liberté d'expression
parce que moi ce que je ressens quand
même chez le ch et marcel gauchet c'est
un peu une sorte de langage désabusé ah
oui ça sera jamais parfait ah oui il y
aura jamais l'égalité et c'est ben non
il faut pas en prendre son parti il faut
pas accepter cette inégalité
structurelles aussi massive dans l'axé à
la liberté d'expression
il faut lutter pour qu' il y ait plus de
démocratie donc plus de d'accès à la
liberté d'expression
d'autres pas justement il y a
contrairement à ce qu'on veut bien nous
faire venir d un certain nombre de
sujets tabous qui sont effectivement
disons ce qu'on pourrait appeler le
sacré républicain et d'autres sujets où
effectivement là non seulement il ya le
droit à la liberté d'expression mais
l'urée presse que le devoir de
caricaturer alors c'est d'ailleurs assez
amusant parce que
emmanuel macron qui à la fois dit nous
défendrons mordicus les caricatures
faisant presque de la défense des
caricatures une affaire d'état et
donnant presque un statut officiel à
certaines caricatures
en même temps depuis 15 jours il passe
son temps à dire mais non les autres
pays caricature la france c'est pas ça
ce que vous dites est caricatural vous
n'avez pas le droit de dire ça et c'est
autrement dit quand ça atteint le le
pouvoir là par contre on n'a pas le
droit de caricaturer alors moi je
préfère qu'on parle d'eux doit à
caricaturer plutôt que le droit à au
blasphème et ce droit a caricaturé il
faut qu'ils soient égales sur tous les
sujets c'est à dire que on a autant le
droit de caricaturer du gouvernement que
de caricaturer tel groupe convictionnels
ou aux religieux ni plus ni moins il
faut essayer de maintenir une balance
égale à celle gauche est ce qu'il faut
est ce qu'on devrait avoir le droit de
caricaturer les homosexuels les femmes
les races en même temps que le prophète
c'est une question infiniment épineuse
qui demanderait de prendre du cas précis
ce qui est en jeu dans cette affaire
c'est le respect de la dignité d'autrui
ou de le respect de la révérence qu'on
doit ou à des institutions ou à des
événements il ya des toutes sortes de
situations où effectivement on a
caricaturé insupportable parce qu'elle
met en question la dignité des
homosexuels de des noirs
les cas sont infinies et vous aviez pour
sa part être vous interrompre c'est que
le respect de la dignité humaine fait
partie des principes républicains
d'ailleurs oui mais c'est leur
appréciation dans la pratique qui fait
toute la difficulté puisque nous parlons
essentiellement jeu comme jean baubérot
je pense qu'il faut pas parler de droit
au blasphème au terme républicain le
blasphème est ignorée du langage
républicain puisqu'il va sur un terrain
rollins apprécié que du point de vue
religieux et n'a pas de sens
la question qui fait que toutes ces
choses se régleront toujours et c'est
dommage d'ailleurs mais c'est ainsi
devant les tribunaux et la marge et
d'appréciation qui sépare la comté de
faire rire de tel ou tel travers imputée
à une collectivité un gros pas eu un
pays
pourquoi la france et se caricature
elle-même le béret basque et la baguette
gebra il devenu une caricature du
français moyen personnes d'ivoire où
d'inconvénients même si c'est très loin
de la réalité
mais et je suppose me viennent y voient
une atteinte à sa dignité
mais comment distinguer ces salles qui
est l'objet de toutes ces questions
autour but du droit au blast nous
prétendu droit au blasphème est de
savoir si en caricaturant le prophète
dans le cas de l'islam on porte atteinte
à la dignité des musulmans
c'est ça la question qui le ressentent
comme une atteinte personnelle et on
doit comprendre qu'ils le ressentent
comme une atteinte personnelle comme
lorsque le christ est tournée en
dérision dans un film dans des
caricatures ont là aussi dans des
oeuvres d'art les catholiques où les
chrétiens en général peuvent le vivre et
on peut le comprendre et on doit le
comprendre comme quelque chose qui met
en question quelque chose qui leur tient
profondément à que la question est très
exactement de savoir ce qui relève de
dans chaque cas et ça ne peut
s'apprécier qu'au cas par cas et pas en
général c'est pourquoi ces discussions
sont terribles lorsqu elles généralisent
des choses qui ne peuvent s'apprécier
constitue à sion et on ne s'en sort
jamais du ray à l'infini où s'arrête la
mise en question de la dignité des
musulmans puisque l'on parle
essentiellement des caricatures de
charlie hebdo et le droit parfaitement
fondées et indiscutable
critique des religions puisque c'est de
ça qu'il s'agit le droit de critique des
religions et 1,10 et intangible mais il
faut savoir qu'il est toujours
susceptible de déraper vers une atteinte
à des personnes et la marge de
l'appréciation est toujours l'objet
d'une discussion d'ordre judiciaire
finalement avec toutes les controverses
qui en découlent on n'arrive jamais à
trouver une mesure exacte mais il faut
être bien avertis on ne peut pas brandir
car je crois qu'il faut se défaire de la
démagogie qui consiste à brandir l'idée
d'un droit inconditionnel qui pourrait
s'appliquer hors de toute limitation de
ces conditions elle s'écrie réaction de
jean baubérot on a juste une minute
avant de faire une pause
je vous donnerai la parole après oui bah
écoutez moi je mettrais en opposition
l'équipe d'hara kiri inquiets qui a été
interdit parce que il avait fait de
caricatures qui disait de le général de
gaulle au moment de la mort du général
de gaulle
autrement dit caricaturait le pouvoir et
l'équipe actuelle de charlie hebdo qui
elle caricature une minorité religieuse
souvent défavorisés socialement et sow
et de manière sociétal bon et
personnellement je préfère hara kiri qui
s'attaquait au pouvoir plutôt que
charlie hebdo c'est également bon
endroit en tant que citoyen en tant que
citoyen mais reconnaissait que la
laïcité française elle ne fait pas la
différence entre les deux bien sûr bien
sûr mais à ce moment là si vous voulez
moi la caricature de cabu barreaux mais
c'est dur d'être aimé par des cons
je suis tout à fait pour mais je suis
tellement pour que j'ajoute à propos
d'un certain courant laïque à laïcité
c'est dur d'être aimé par des cons
voilà on y revient juste après une pause
[Musique]
olivier le revenu universel utopie ou
vraie solution face à la crise et non
vraie bêtise c'est à dire que vous
dépendrez entièrement de l'état le
problème du revenu et recel c'est
effectivement il y aura une contrepartie
ce sera conva supprimer un certain
nombre d' aide c'est extrêmement
dangereux parce que finalement les 9 2
millions de pauvres
on annonce les livres vont être encore
plus haut c'est un espèce de nivellement
par le bas c'est à dire tout le monde à
750 euros mais avec 750 euros vous
pouvez vivre les entreprises on
attendait juste plus la peine de payer
2000 euros des gens ils ont déjà doit
cette saison avec huit mois là on parle
de 400 milliards pour faire un revenu
universel et 400 milliards c'est 20 %
ont pib on fait comment on les sort d'où
le crime est tellement épouvantable que
je pense qu'une partie de l'église mais
comme une partie de la société ne veut
pas le voir de 1950 à aujourd'hui le
travail de la commission a permis
d'identifier trois mille victimes 1500
agresseurs ces chiffres sont forcément
très en deçà de la réalité puisque des
victimes sont décédées des victimes ne
peuvent pas parler peut-être ne
parleront jamais ça montre cette
tragédie qui lie à un système au tour
c'est-à-dire comment des agresseurs ont
ils pu agresser 10/20 parfois trente ans
nous sommes loin du bout du chemin à
vous savez des institutions se réforment
lentement l'église peut être encore plus
lentement je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas je pense que la prise de conscience
est fait de tels scandales de tels
drames de telles tragédies dans la vie
oblige à la vérité
[Musique]
alors venant dans ce débat entre jean
baubérot et marcel gaucher est la
laïcité au principe de laïcité qui lui
est un principe républicain
est ce que c'est à ce principe que le
gouvernement est en train de s'attaquer
à la fois avec la loi sur le séparatisme
mais aussi en voulant dissoudre
l'observatoire de la laïcité pour en
faire une structure portant la parole de
l'état comme l'a annoncé marlène
schiappa est ce qu'on est en train de
passer d'une laïcité apaisée que vous
avez toujours défendu jean baubérot et
dont vous pensiez que emmanuel macron la
défendent est lui aussi à une laïcité de
combat que défendrait plus tôt marcel
gauchet même s'il trouve que ça n'est
toujours pas la laïcité de combat 7
cette loi sion de séparatisme alors est
ce qu'on est en train de changer de
laïcité jean baubérot vous qu'il avait
enseigné la laxité pendant des années et
bien
enfin il ya toujours eu des
représentations différentes de la
laïcité et en 1905 la loi de 1905 est
issue non seulement d'un conflit entre
deux france la france catholique et puis
la france issu de la révolution
française mais elle est aussi issu d'un
combat entre laïques entre plusieurs
sortes de laïcs et ceux qui ont gagné
c'est des laïcs qu'on appelait des
socialo pas pas l'un c'est à dire
brillant jaurès qui ont effectivement
voulu que la victoire de la laïcité soit
une victoire pacificatrice est donc
cette victoire pacificatrice en fait
elle a coupé le bloc catholique en deux
elle a permis d'isoler certains
extrémistes et elle a justement permis
cet apaisement qui a duré des décennies
et maintenant il faut refaire un peu le
même chemin par rapport à l'islam
marcel gaucher et après
oui la laïcité ce sont des principes qui
ne bouge pas mais la compréhension on a
de ces principes elle a considérablement
évolué au moment de 1950 la loi de
séparation des églises et de l'état est
adopté non le conflit est majeur même si
j'en ai fait l'analyse de jean baubérot
c'est tout à fait juste
ce ne sont pas les laïcs qui entendait
mettre derrière la laïcité
le projet d'éradication des religions
c'était ça le l'enjeu mais l'acceptation
faire mieux et ce qu'il l'a emporté pour
dire les choses simplement
et depuis lors il l'a ce que j'ai
proposé d'appeler l'entrée de la
religion dans la démocratie la religion
en l'occurrence étant le catholicisme
romain qui ne l'oublions pas 1905 est
majoritairement anti républicain même
s'il ya déjà des catholiques
républicains au nombre tout à fait
significatif nous avons une considérable
l'évolution de la laïcité dans sa
conception qui fait que ce n'était même
plus dans les années 60 1970 1980
c'était plus un vrai sujet or des
historiens y avait plus de batailles
laïque
le dernière grande bataille lights et
ont joué autour de l'enseignement de
l'école est bon comme vous disais allez
pas
et alors simplement le fait nouveau
récent qui a complètement remaniée
rebattu les cartes et ramener les
discussions sur ce terrain c'est
l'irruption via l' immigration musulmane
d'une religion qui n'étaient pas prises
en compte dans le cadre laïc
traditionnelle qui était un dialogue
république contre l'église catholique
là on arrive avec l'islam devant une
nouvelle religion que d'abord on connaît
mal et qui ensuite en effet et leur lit
religion minoritaire en france mais une
religion est normal et chef du monde est
l'un de nos problèmes
tiens au décalage entre ce que nous
vivons nous comme la minorité religieuse
musulmane en france et le bloc musulmans
très divers d'ailleurs qui lui et
regroupe le plus d'un milliard de
personnes un homme et des pays
extrêmement différent donc minorité chez
nous mais énormes blocs civilisationnel
par ailleurs et l'interaction entre les
deux brouille les cartes d'autant qu'une
partie de notre problème tient à
l'intervention de gouvernements
étrangers musulmans dans les affaires
françaises bien leur l'immigration qui
ressort de leur pays
donc nous avons 1 1 entre deux
évolutions une évolution qui apaise la
laïcité entre catholiques et
républicains la laïcité traditionnel et
un choc en retour de l'arrivée de cette
nouvelle religion avec ses problèmes
propres qui serait qui ne se réduisent
évidemment par la relative pauvreté de
la grande majorité des musulmans
présents sur le sol français ce qui
personnellement pour parce que cette
évolution est due significative mon cas
n'a aucun intérêt particulier n'était
qu' il est typique dans un premier temps
j'ai pensé que assez naturellement
l'islam allait se fondre dans cette
évolution générale du que nous avions
observé qui avait neutralisé la question
religieuse en france en permettant à la
fois la liberté complète de conscience
des décomptes des croyants et le respect
des règles républicaines et gilles a
fallu s'apercevoir que la question était
beaucoup plus compliquée nous deux en ce
qui me concerne l'idée que nous allions
devoir dans des conditions qui n'ont
rien à voir avec celle de 1905 de la
lutte pour la république laïque revenir
à une laïcité de combat pour faire
prévaloir face à annie cela
de combat est le combat ne se limitant
pas au djihadisme une vision laïque de
la tolérance que nous devons en effet
avoir la plus complète liberté de
pratiquer leur religion dans le respect
du cadre républicain qui est visé par
une minorité activistes musulmane on en
a les moyens du jour jean baubérot oui
alors si vous voulez aussi bien marcel
gauchet que moi même on n'accorde pas
mal d'importance à à l'épaisseur
historique d'une société c'est pour ça
je voudrais d'abord revenir un peu sur
la loi de 1905 parce que moi je ne suis
pas d'accord avec cette opposition
binaire que fait marcel entre ceux qui
ont voulu éradiquer la religion et est
brillant et je reste de l'autre côté en
fait il y avait quatre représentations
je vais aller très vite
il y avait effectivement ce qui voulait
éradiquer la religion mais c'était une
petite minorité 50 députés à peu près il
y avait ceux qui voulaient la purifier
là c'était déjà plus important est
qu'ils n'étaient pas contre la religion
mais qui pensaient qu'il fallait un
catholicisme républicain qu'il fallait
république disait le catholicisme et
puis il y avait ceux qui étaient dans la
le républicanisme classique c'est-à-dire
pour la liberté de religion et de
croyance était d'abord individuelle et
elle se prolonge et ensuite par l'acte
collectif dudu du culte etc
c'était par exemple clément souhait
c'est que les manceaux qui a accusé
jaurès et et brillant d'être des socialo
papa là c'est pas c'est pas ce qu'ils
voulaient éradiquer la religion c'est ce
qui était dans le républicanisme
classique pour est brillant et jaurès
qui était dans une culture plus
syndicaliste plus socialiste et cetera
ils ont fait cet article 4 qui était
originaire des états unis et clémence
aurait pu les accusés d'être des socialo
américain si mais il n'a pas fait parce
que lui même était un admirateur de la
belgique
mais qui ont introduit dans la
législation française
un élément qui provenaient de la
législation américaine
reconnaissons que les églises avec une
organisation générale est que cette
organisation générale elle devait être
respectée par la république
bon donc ça va beaucoup plus loin que
que cette opposition binaire que fait
marc cette gauche est bon et alors en
quoi ça ça c'est intéressant pour
aujourd'hui c'est parce que c'est grâce
à cela que effectivement on a pu à part
le problème de l'enseignement qui
effectivement a été un conflit
substitutif on a pu vivre en paix dans
un indice un suspect a continué parce
que l'église catholique croit toujours à
une loi naturelle qui s'imposerait à
tous les humains et qui a été retiré de
contrôle des naissances qui interdirait
l'avortement qui interdirait le mariage
des personnes de même sexe etc
le dissensus entre la laïcité et le
catholicisme
il existe toujours il existe toujours et
pourtant on arrive à vivre en paix
pourquoi et bien parce que les
catholiques en fait ils trient dans le
catholicisme et itri dans le
catholicisme d'autant plus qu' ils sont
à l'aise dans la société française et
pour moi le problème c'est de faire la
même chose avec les musulmans c'est à
dire que on n'a pas un islam qui serait
unique
bien sûr il ya peut-être un milliard de
musulmans dans le monde
mais ce milliard de musulmans i d'abord
il ya yami l'islam et il ya un
spécialiste de l'islam qui parle de
l'anarchie des fatwas bon mais ensuite
même dans cet islam le rapport à l'islam
des musulmans est un rapport où il ya du
tri alors ce tri y va effectivement de
ce que j'appelle l'ultra islamisme donc
d un radicalisme religieux qui est
dangereux ah au fait que moi je j'ai
interviewé par exemple une foi musulmane
qui me disaient oui oui je fais le
ramadan mais je considère pas que la
bière c'est d'alcool bon c'est à dire
que il ya beaucoup de mu
le mans qui ont une religiosité
personnel où ils se servent d'eux des
ressources disons donné par l'islam
comme des ressources qui peuvent les
aider à vivre et ils prennent ce qui
leur paraît important et intéressant
et puis le reste il le contourne il
s'arrange avec le ciel comme on dit bon
et donc la république se doit d'être
attractive et c'est en étant attractif
que elle facilitera disons le
développement de cet islam l'a22 de cet
islam où les gens trient selon ce qui
leur paraît raisonnable ou pas selon ce
qui leur paraît vivable ou pas beau mais
plus évidemment on se braquera plus on
sera dans un combat plus y aura des
camps constitués et des extrémistes
musulmans pourront dire ne trahissez pas
d'islam en étant pro républicain etc
mais actuellement dash et les
djihadistes heureusement ils ont pas
beaucoup d'échos parce qu'étant donné
qu'il ya environ quatre millions de
musulmans en france
si les quatre millions de musulmans
étaient produits jihadistes la vie
serait invivable tous les jours c'est
toutes les minutes que vous auriez des
attentats s'est pas de temps en temps
comme malheureusement c'est le cas où un
attentat c'est toujours arrêtant pas
trop mais heureusement la plupart des
musulmans sont tout à fait acclimaté à
la république française simplement s'ils
sont victimes de discriminations s'ils
sont victimes d'inégalités
eh bien ils peuvent effectivement
écouter les sirènes extrémistes et c'est
ça qu'il faut éviter à celle gauche et
c'est sûrement ce qu'il faut éviter
mais je ne suis pas sûr que cette image
du tri soit la bonne le problème n'est
pas de savoir ce qu'on prend est-ce
qu'on laisse il est d'opérer une
distinction dans le cas des catholiques
la conscience catholique moyenne compte
tenu du fait qu'il ya aussi les
extrémistes catholiques très minoritaire
le problème est d'accepter la séparation
entre ce qui est de l'ordre d'une
conviction personnelle et après tout il
n'ya pas besoin d'être catholique pour
être par exemple hostiles à l'avortement
c'est un problème de conscience beaucoup
plus large qui touche évidemment en
priorité des convictions religieuses
mais qui tous aussi des gens qui n'ont
aucune conviction religieuse
particulière mais qui voilà quelque
chose d'insupportable pour des raisons
éthiques
avant tout à fait respectable la
question n'est pas de savoir quelle est
l'opinion qu'on éprouve à l'égard de ces
sujets la question de savoir si ces
opinions doivent prévaloir puisqu'elles
sont bénéficie d'une légitimité
supérieure à celle des lois de la
république
l'idée de la république se résume en un
mot il c'est ce qui fait que la laïcité
est en son centre
il n'y a pas de loi de dieu on ne peut
pas opposer à ou le bois débattues
discutées à l'égard desquels on peut
avoir toutes les positions qu'on veut
quand la règle majoritaire et respecter
la loi qui est en vigueur on la respecte
indépendamment de l'opinion qu'on peut
en avoir religieuses ou non
c'est ça le point or nous nous trouvons
avec l'islam pour des raisons qui n'ont
rien de mystérieux avec ils tiennent
moins contenue à trensacq de la religion
musulmane qu'est ce qu'on aurait pu dire
la même chose de la religion chrétienne
il ya quelques siècles car la situation
historique qui est la sienne le point
contentieux c'est l'idée qu'il y à une
loi religieuse qui est au dessus des
lois de la république
et ça c'est un point de philosophie de
la république sur lequel la discussion
n'est pas possible il n'ya plus de
république appartient moment où on admet
qu'il ya au dessus de la loi de la
république des lois de la république
une loi religieuse qui peut s'imposer
s'agissant puisqu'on connaît tous la
question des la question majeure qui est
posée par gyan le statut des femmes
mais y en a bien d'autres 10 et le fait
est qu'il y a
blême historique de l'islam qui ne
malheureusement ne relève pas que de
notre compétence et de nos capacités
l'islam est ce qu'ils les deux parce que
l'histoire en a fait de ce que le monde
arabo musulman puisque c'est celui qui
nous concerne plus directement
même s'il dit cela me va bien au delà et
et dans son état actuel avec le saut
culturel que ça suppose qu'ils valent
par exemple s'exprimer aussi bien à
l'école dans l'idée de du refus de la
théorie de l'évolution qui fait partie
de l'enseignement scientifique de
basiques qui est distribué dans nos
établissements au titre de l'éducation
nationale indispensable et la question
est là il y à une can nous sommes dans
un choc culturel que nous ne pouvons pas
ignorer à mon sens avec d'islam comme
cela dit le but étant effectivement de
favoriser l'adhésion des musulmans aux
valeurs qui sont celles de la société
dans laquelle ils vivent et de leur
permettre de se rallier ce qu'ils font
en très grand nombre
en effet dieu merci c'est ce propos peu
laïque mettant dans notre vocabulaire de
tous les jours
évidemment qu'il faut le but est
l'intégration dans le cadre laïc mais
cette intégration ne va pas sans un choc
culturel vis-à-vis duquel nous ne
pouvons pas nous voiler la face
jean baubérot oui alors bon d'abord le
problème n'est pas que les gens estiment
par exemple que l'avortement leur est
interdit et qu' ils pratiqueront jaber
avortement le problème quand je peux pas
j'ai parlé de la loi naturelle c'est que
pour l'église catholique la loi
naturelle elle s'impose à toute personne
quel que que cette personne soit
catholique ou pas et la loi naturelle
c'est l'église catholique qui la définit
donc dans l'eau au coeur même de
l'église catholique
il ya cette revendication d'être porteur
d'une loi universelle qui conservait
tous les êtres humains
et est qui qui est un 10 ans us avec les
principes laïques dissensus théorique
qui n'a pas été résolu et qui justement
le pari d'aristide briand c'est de dire
qui faisait dire en 1905 à beaucoup de
gens que le catholicisme et la
république étaient incompatibles et
aristide briand à 10 elles sont de poser
le problème dans ces termes
cessons de poser de problème dans cet
art voyons de manière pragmatique
pratique comment on peut fonctionner et
je crois que c'est une erreur grave très
grave de recommencer
axel dauchez aurait existé en 1905 il
aurait été contre pillant il aurait
pensé qu'il y avait une incompatibilité
un choc culturel entre le catholicisme
et la république bon non les problèmes
sur la scène loi de dieu non moi je
n'aime pas ce vocabulaire religieux
employés par des républicains
bon ce qu'on la république a constaté c
est ce que les gens dans leur vie
concrète respectent les lois de la
république coupable il ya des gens qui
respectent pas les lois de la république
mais me to a montré que ces gens par
exemple sur l'égalité hommes femmes
on est mal classé pour focaliser sa sur
les musulmans étant donné que dans tous
les milieux que l'égalité homme femme
n'a pas été respectée la dignité des
femmes n'a pas été respecté et dans les
milieux les plus branchés les pluies
les bleus qui se voulait les plus
modernes donc ayons le même regard pour
tout le monde et demandons à tout le
monde de respecter autant que faire se
peut les principes républicains
mais on n'a pas se soucier de théologie
la théologie c'est une affaire privée
c'est bon c'est pas du tout à la
république de de se focaliser sur tel ou
tel théologie en sachant que justement
il ya moi je vois derrière le propos de
marcel boscher un peu un essentialisme
un un islam qui de tout temps et partout
serez serait un peu le même un bloc pour
moi il n'y a pas de bloc
bon il ya un problème historique parce
que on a des listes des histoires
contrat ce fait on peut quand même pas
enlever toute l'histoire de la
colonisation
et effectivement il ya eu un
raidissement d'un certain nombre de
théologiens musulmans à partir du 19ème
siècle et de l'emprise occidentale mais
maintenant il y à une diversité très
grande en islam est la meilleure preuve
d'ailleurs c'est que ce sont des
musulmans qui sont le plus atteint par
le terrorisme islamique
les plus grandes victimes au niveau
quantitatif ce sont des musulmans eux
mêmes
donc il ya une grande variété dans la
matière d'être musulman comme une grande
variété dans la manière d'être
catholique et c'est pas le problème la
république de se focaliser sur les
doctrines le problème la république
c'est d'organiser un vivre ensemble
inclusif pour que des gens se sentent
bien dans la république ayant des droits
respecte les devoirs qu'ils ont
également et il ya une dialectique des
droits et des devoirs et plus les gens
auront des droits plus on leur pourra
leur demander d'avoir des devoirs et il
ya une dernière question c'est faut-il
républicaniser les religions saab et
était voulue par certains vous le dit
et jean baubérot en 1905 faut-il le
faire aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
faut-il au nom de l'égalité hommes
femmes
allez voir les catholiques et réformés
l'église catholique pour que de manier
des femmes prêtres après tout il ya des
familles mam il ya des femmes rabbins
il n'y a pas de femmes prêtres faut-il
républicaniser la religion catholique
lui dire qu'il faut quelques semaines à
comprendre l'avortement aller voir les
musulmans les juifs leur dire que
maintenant il serait peut-être temps de
manger du jambon et cetera et cetera
à sa gauche et oui je vais pas vraiment
le sujet un mode de vie si aisément si
nous sommes républicains
nous respectons l'autonomie de la
société civile l'église catholique règle
ses affaires en interne et si les
catholiques ne sont pas contents ils
peuvent toujours quitter leur église
ça ne nous concerne pas je pense pas que
justement république à 10 des religions
serait réalisé une intrusion sur le
terrain de ce qu'elles ont à être que
qui doit un qui doit nous être interdit
je reviens sur le point essentiel de
notre discussion avec jean baubérot en
effet la république ne doit pas
s'occuper de théologie le pôle des
problèmes de doctrine bêta physique lui
sont étrangers
chacun est libre de cultiver les
adhésions qui lui paraissent les bonnes
en la matière mais en revanche la
république ne peut pas se désintéresser
des conséquences pratiques que les uns
et les autres tirent de leurs
convictions métaphysique ou religieuse
et c'est bien pour ça qu'il faut se
poser qu'on est amené volage dollar même
si on n'a aucune envie de le faire pour
raisons pour lesquelles les sont
invoquées les justifications de telle ou
telle conduite une telle ou telle
revendication le traitement différencié
des hommes et des femmes étant l'exemple
le plus caractéristique le seul
traitement différencié on peut dire nous
ne regarde donc les faits et sont contre
le nain là ils sont contre les principes
d'égalité républicain mais nous devons
regarder
les motivations ou non dès qu'elle s'est
présentée comme une revendication
indiscutable par certains donc en effet
on peut reconnaître la légitimité de la
liberté de conscience mais on est obligé
de se poser la question pratique et la
question en l'occurrence c'est une cette
idée de l'indépendance absolue du
législateur humain qui est après qu on
escompte que l'église catholique peut
penser tout ce qu'elle veut ça nous est
complètement indifférent dès lors
qu'elle admet le principe républicain de
la suprématie du législateur civile
c'est tout et là il ya la discussion et
port très exactement sur ce point une
aile et d'applications ce point une
application quotidienne ne le voyons
nous le voyons tous et je crois pas par
ailleurs ces ventres points qui nous
séparent probablement jean baubérot et
moi même si on fait ça vaut beaucoup de
terrain commun dans l'appréciation
historique
là dessus je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
réduire réduire le problème de l'islam
aujourd'hui à un problème lié à la
colonisation même si dans le cas des
musulmans que nous avons sur notre
territoire
c'est un élément qui compte évidemment
dans la manière dont ils peuvent
appréhender la la france et son histoire
le problème est posé par l'islam et
celui de son nine adéquation à la
culture moderne qui est fondamentalement
une culture critique une culture
critique des religions mais pas
seulement une culture autocritique pour
commencer et qui créent qu'on le veuille
ou non un écart de 2 qui ne se résoudra
j'en suis convaincu d'ailleurs
historiquement par l'acculturation à la
culture moderne du monde musulman qui
est en cours et il est en train de se
produire
il n'empêche que cela nous impose à mon
sens
vigilance tout à fait particulière une
rigueur très grande à l'égard d'un type
de discours est d'un type de prêt
tensions sociales et politiques face
auquel nous devons avoir une attitude
extrêmement ferme pour faciliter cette
intégration de cette acculturation qui
est le but nous sommes d'accord là
dessus
quelle est la meilleure manière
d'aboutir au but que nous souhaitons en
commun voilà le langer de notre débat
est bien juste innu l'émission juste se
termine je vous remercie tous les deux
d'y avoir participé
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]